welcome to the latest edition of just
getting started i'm your humble host
rich eisen fresh back from
my nfl network gig as the host of the
nfl draft
in cleveland ohio and that's part of the
reason why
my guest this week on just getting
started is the miz
the great wwe superstar himself
from parma ohio he's a die-hard
cleveland brown
fan he's a die-hard ohioan and i figured
who better to have on this podcast
telling his story his origin story from
reality show star to wwe star
and telling you the backstory of just
how much work he put into it to get to
this spot
and hopefully you can pull something
from his story and bring it to your
world if you want to just get started on
something new that's what this pods all
about
so let's get started with the miz
and joining me on just getting started
is somebody who i've gotten a chance to
know
for uh many a moon because i played
fantasy football against him believe it
or not in an alice in chains fantasy
football league and it's somebody who's
career
i've admired quite a bit which makes him
a perfect guest for just getting started
the miz joining me here uh
with a beautiful wwe background behind
him how are you miss
that's how we do it i mean i am
literally uh getting ready for tv
right now so i'm in tampa i'm not even
at my home studio so i had to find a
room that's actually
quiet to actually do this in but for you
anything you know i
i got a little little bone to pick okay
so you brought everybody
for your your st juice run uh to
sofi stadium and they all did 40s and
i'm like
where's my invite i want to do a 40
at sofi stadium just like everybody else
well that was part of this thing was to
just throw it together
last minute and then do it in such a way
that people can't get enough of seeing
it and they want to do it so would you
do it
next year are you already committing
yourself to running a 40-yard dash for
st
jude next year
i'm i am 100 committed if i can be at
sofi
stadium running a 40 uh where the
the the rams play i am totally in and
honestly
i might be able to beat some of the
legends that you had
i mean these guys are hall of famers i
know i can beat you that's no doubt in
my mind i'll wear my suit and everything
i'll go so that's the thing is that
you would have to wear a suit i would
want you in an actual suit just like me
because the suit you know as as slow as
i am
um it does act like a parachute it does
you know
actually keep me from running a split
tenth of a second faster which is the
difference between breaking six seconds
or not
and i can already see you agree with my
assessment ms
i already see that i
i do actually agree with that but not
only that though i'm wondering what kind
of suit you're using
because nowadays they have these stretch
suits like right now i have this on
right now you probably
if you can hear you can't you know
you're not watching it on tv but i mean
if you are not
then whatever but this suit i'm wearing
right now is one that you can actually
run in because it actually stretches
you know they have these amazing stretch
suits and so i'm wondering what
what suit are you wearing is this just a
regular suit that you've had customly
fit to your body
or is this a stretch yes last two years
i was running in sweat taylor
um because they were also a sponsor of
the run
and this year i threw everything
together to the point where
the fact that this ran took place at all
uh in the last
you know two months um was
um was quite something to say the least
to put it all together and get everybody
there and raise as much money as
everybody was kind enough to put in the
kitty
um so i did not really have much
sponsors lined up or anything so i just
ran in my regular
brunello cuccinelli perfectly finely
italian tailored suitcase
and you look great doing it i'll tell
you why everyone else looked great doing
it as well and anytime you do something
for such an amazing college as in saint
jude's
that's incredible every year i i
honestly i almost look more
more forward to you running the 40 than
i do
uh the draft especially this year
because to be honest my cleveland browns
didn't really need to do anything in the
draft like
i was like people were always like dude
you know the the draft is in cleveland
you should be really excited i'm like
normally the browns are like the first
draft pick or the first five
you know we don't have until the 26th
pick
like people like who do you want i'm
like i don't know whoever's left
you know as a quarterback i mean what
what am i supposed to do i mean this is
one of the first years where i look at
it and i go
we've done everything in free agency so
i'm ready for us to just go to the super
bowl and win the damn thing
well and that's part of the reason why i
want to have you on because you know i
just got back from ohio and you're a
parma ohio
kid and uh who's done nothing but
succeed
from you know from parma ohio and and
and as i've reached out to you you know
to to be on this
pod you know because you're your story
i'm fascinated by and that's what this
is about is our origin stories
in getting people to tell the way that
they got started
how how did you get started is is
mtv the beginning or is there another
origin story that we need to know about
about how you got started on your career
path and the life that we
i mean we now know mtv was definitely my
start
into the entertainment world but i've
always been a huge wwe fan ever since i
was a kid
man i was i had every action figure
uh i i every time we would go to toys r
us i would beg my parents to get me the
new one that came out like i need the
new ultimate warrior you gotta get it
for me mom please
you know give me some face paint so i
can paint my face like the ultimate
warrior oh look at these streamers i
could use them as
armbands like the ultimate warrior can
like that was
me as a child i was an absolute loon but
when i went to college miami ohio i
looked at my life and i was
you know i was i was a business major uh
because that's what you do when you're
done with high school you go to college
you
i didn't know what i wanted to be or
what i wanted to do so i went into
business classes was doing terrible in
them
and saw a tryout for the real world and
i was like i would love to do this show
oh my god to travel to some city live
with seven strangers
learn about the city of different
cultures different everything
is like my favorite show on tv and so
when i saw that there was an opportunity
to try out i did and what a lot of
people don't know is when you try out
it's not just you try out and all of a
sudden you make it
it's like a six-month process i went
through
uh the first step was trying out i did a
video on my vhs tape at the time
and it literally i would put the vhs
tape a cord in there and a cord in my
vhs player and plus play and record to
try to do editing we didn't have like
apple like
cool editing technique that people have
these days
we didn't have any of that i had to
press play and record on
on some sort of tape recorder and so i
did that and then i
to the next round so i waited like three
weeks for them to get back to me
the next round was like a 50-page
application asking everything and
anything about my life
and then the next round was like three
weeks later
and it was like i had to put the vhs
tape on my
on on like a stand and then press
uh uh have them on a speakerphone and
they would ask me questions and i had to
speak to the video
and then send the video to them so they
could see it we didn't have
zoom back then and then i did two of
those auditions did it in personnel
edition and then i had to go
to palm springs for uh where we
it was the first time they ever did this
where we just met everybody like i met
people
on on that we're gonna be on the
on the it's like before they actually
make it on the show
so then i got there and uh then i made
it onto the real world
and that's kind of where everything
started if john murray and mary ellis
didn't pick me to be on the real world i
wouldn't be sitting here today
do you own or rent your home sure you do
and i bet it could be hard work
you know what's easy bundling policies
with geico
geico makes it easy to handle your home
owners or renters insurance along with
your auto policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com
well i mean you also wouldn't be where
you are if you had you know
not stuck to sending tapes and all that
stuff did you at any point think what
the hell am i doing this for i don't
really have a shot or anything oh yeah
everyone was telling me that like all my
friends
in in family like they're like you're
not gonna make it 60 000 people try out
what's going to stand you out it's just
not going to happen it doesn't happen to
to to to people you know it just doesn't
happen
to us and it did because i just kept
kept going for it and uh and when i made
it they were all like
whoa like that's not supposed to happen
and then it started made me
making me realize that like even when
people tell you that you can't do
something and that it's just because
they can't believe they can't do it
themselves
it doesn't mean that you can't that's
fascinating to me it really is because
that's such a
major aspect of why i wanted to start
this pod is the number of times that
people can just sit there and think you
know what
there's really no shot and then they
could just say that they
kind of gave it a try or didn't really
give it that much for trying to at least
tell themselves that they did
and that it does take an actual
you know certain determination and
obviously you've had that ever since you
even got
accepted uh to that opportunity and have
made like look
look what you're right now i mean you
ever sit back and wonder what the hell
your whole journey's been like that's
pretty amazing
when you think about it yeah you know
right now wwe
has a documentary on me that just came
out on peacock called
ww24 the miz and it was the first time
that i sat
down and talked about my entire career
in totality
and it wasn't the miz it was mike and it
was the first time i did an interview
where it wasn't spliced in of the miz
and mike it was just me
talking being honest and raw about my
career and it made me start realizing
like
wow i've i've really done a lot of great
things in my life
like when i set out to do something like
why it happened
and i'm starting to realize why it
happened it's because i'm just
relentless
at everything i do i want it to be
perfect i want it to be great
before i got on this podcast i literally
was like all right i want this to be
amazing i want this to be great
just because i don't know it's just the
way i am it's just the way i'm wired
and i'll sacrifice everything to get to
where i need to be
and a lot of people will like you were
saying will say yeah i want to do this
and i'll try it and they'll try it for a
week and when it gets hard
they stop because it got hard it it
like with wwe like i remember going to
my first
um this was before wwe i moved
so when i got off the real world i
started doing those challenges
and started making t-shirts my own
t-shirts by the way because i saw that
if you're a wwe superstar
oh man like if they see that i'm people
are buying my own t-shirts and i have my
own website that people are going to to
buy these t-shirts and these t-shirts
are on tv
that maybe they'll see me and go oh this
guy can sell he has a character
he has a fan base let's sign him up and
that wasn't the case
so i moved to los angeles started on an
independent wrestling scene
uh i started training with ultimate pro
wrestling
upw as an independent wrestling scene at
the time to learn the art of
professional wrestling
but not only that i moved out to la to
get an acting classes because i knew
that was a tool
that i would need for wwe then i had
improv classes with improv olympics and
the groundlings
because i knew those improv skills would
be needed because it's a live audience
it's one take i know that is with wwe
so i'm lining up all these tools to get
to make sure that i can be successful in
wwe and was it hard
absolutely i moved away from everything
i knew
i i knew cleveland ohio that's all i
knew i knew i had my family and my
friends i had my core nucleus there
and i moved away from them and i was
broke when you're on the real world
like you want to be like on like live
the life you know you're like um
i'm filming you know you're spending all
your money maxing out all your credit
cards
because you think that they pay for
everything they don't like they want it
to be real what's real in life so
i was broke when i moved to la
and i was just trying to and then
finally i won a challenge that
gave me enough money to where i could
you know i
invested in myself i i didn't go buy a
new car or
go buy new clothes no i invested in a
wrestling school
acting classes and improv classes a
dietitian
and a gym membership because those were
all the things that i needed
to make sure that i could still do it
and then i was selling t-shirts on the
side
and so it was just one of those things
that i wasn't
going to be told no so anybody
who did actually make it into comedy
that you were
you were in the groundlings with that
you were there that you remember anybody
who kayla watkins
was my teacher and she was on snl okay
she
she did a season of snl she's and by the
way she's a bunch of like
like she's an actress in a ton of like
uh
you know sitcoms she's always like every
season i see her on a new sitcom
and she was fantastic she was great so
um
when did the wwe finally come knocking
when did this whole master plan that you
had that i guess started from having the
action figures you're begging your
mother for
as the kid in parma ohio when did it
actually come true when did that
lightning strike
for you i would say about three and a
half years later of training
being on reality shows after reality
shows telling everybody that i could
possibly tell that i want to be a w
superstar
finally uh i got a call from the tough
enough people
and said hey do you want to try out for
tough enough and if you know what tough
enough is tough enough is
wwe's reality show where you could win a
contract to be a wwe superstar
but here's the kicker like i tried out
to be on tough enough and they wouldn't
let me because tough enough used to be
on mtv and
real world was on mtv and the challenges
were on mtv and back then
you couldn't intermix all those
different things like back then
it was a whole different world like
nowadays you look at
you know reality tv everything's a
reality show instagram
youtube you know tick tock i know
exactly what the biggest movie star in
the world is doing because i go on his
instagram and see it
you know what i mean the birthday boy
yesterday was uh having a grand old time
i guess
as i'm talking about the rock but um but
so it's
it's interesting to me you know when you
look at things
like how they progress like look at the
world we live in nowadays like
everything is a reality show everyone
is on a reality show everyone knows what
everyone's doing
and when i was on a reality show that
wasn't the case
you weren't you weren't applauded and
and loved and liked in hollywood as a
matter of fact i couldn't even get into
a room
to audition because they didn't want you
you were a
known good nothing hack of a talent
that can just be on tv and have a camera
pointed at them and be entertaining
and so wwe wasn't calling and i wasn't
allowed to do tough enough because it
was
different back then and then tough
enough went on to the cw
and they were like hey since it's on cw
you can try out now so i tried out
50 contestants and i made i think the
top eight and then i
was the runner-up i didn't win but it
was by audience
reaction and if anyone knows anything
about me with wwe i've always been a
very good
person to hate and uh uh i've always
been
a bad guy so you know uh i looked at
that
as honestly a blessing disguised and it
was funny i so in the wwe 24 doc
they showed me doing an interview that
i've never seen before
and it was like man it would have been
really great
to have a wwe contract and the bonus i
mean
obviously the bonus to win a million
dollars but i really wanted that
contract in my head i'm going
a million dollars you could have won a
million dollars and all you're talking
about is a contract for wwe
like i was like wow like even back then
my mindset
wasn't about the money i saw the career
and the want and the love and the fun
and it wasn't about the money and that's
what you need to find
when you're looking for a job like i
imagine you love what you do
you can tell you love what you do rich
like you love
interviewing people you love talking
about sports you enjoy it it's just it's
something that you do like
and so with me i love being a wwe
superstar i love going out there each
and every week granted right now
there isn't a live audience but i love
hearing the live reaction
to an audience and hearing them and
feeling them and getting that initial
response
there's nothing quite like it anywhere
else you know and it
you could see it you know i'm just
talking to you in the few times that
i've
gotten to be in the same room as you and
talking to you it's
you could see you're like living your
best life man you friggin made it like
you
did it and now here you are like with
wwe
uh backdrop behind you getting ready to
shoot raw what what's your favorite
story that you can share that you might
not tell often but your favor like
of of of your are we talking about wwe
or like as yeah
like honestly if you're talking about my
favorite lifetime stories it's it'd be
with my kids
sure like i i love being a dad like i
enjoy being around my daughters
each and every day uh my daughter my one
and a half year old right now
my favorite thing is when she wakes up
in the morning and she goes
and then she'll show me her baby which
is as big as her like the baby's big as
her
and she'll pick it up and if she drops
it and i'm holding her school baby
and she'll hold it and then i'll watch
her like when i tuck her in at night
she'll hold the baby like this and i'm
like oh it's just there's some
something magic about it like yesterday
i took my daughter golfing right
yeah and uh i take her all the time
she's three
monroe is three madison is one and a
half and
oh god it is it's it's amazing to watch
her
like being out like some people are like
what do you like to bring your golfing
for because there's bunnies everywhere
and she likes to see the bunnies hop and
so we'll go be really quiet
be really quiet okay okay okay and were
you trying to sneak up on the bunnies
and just watch them and see them
and then right now there's tadpoles in
in uh the ponds
and so she'll see the tadpoles and
they're turning into frogs and it's like
you can just educate her and see
the the eyes like widen and go oh wow
tadpoles and then or the duckies and the
baby duckies and so we'll go home and
she'll tell her mom all these little
stories about golf and guess what
i get to play my favorite sport which is
golf
[Laughter]
it's a win-win situation hey man hey man
tiger started at three on the bob hope
show i think that's when he was out
there and bob
i mean on the mike douglas show with bob
hope swinging it as a three-year-old so
you know putting the stick in your
daughter's hand at age three
never know man yeah i mean she swings it
like a hockey stick i feel like she gets
it from my wife because my wife's
canadian
uh but uh i've been trying to teach her
she wants to do it on her own so i'll
let her hit the ball
on her own it's it's honestly one of the
the best things that i have i mean you
talk about
your best stories and i don't know a
parent
that wouldn't have their best story have
their kids in it no question
i agree with you you know i got three i
got a uh 12
10 and a seven and you know uh trying to
be present is definitely a challenge but
it's also a blessing too you know
let's talk about audible people my
family we listen to books on audible all
the time
and it makes long road trips so much
easier when we say hey who wants to
listen to a book on audible they're all
in on it as a matter of fact
my daughter the other day went to my
wife and said mom
can we get this book on audible my
daughter is seven and she knows all
about audible but what
many of us don't already know about is
audible plus
with an audible plus membership you get
full access to the plus catalog
audible plus is all about giving members
a chance to listen to and discover new
favorites
and explore different formats now you
can listen all you want to thousands and
thousands of popular audiobooks
original entertainment and podcasts
including ad-free versions
of your favorite shows and exclusive
series you'll also find
guided fitness meditation and sleep
tracks for better rest
all available to download in streams so
you can listen anywhere on any device
with everything you'll love to listen to
all in one app
audible plus is your playlist for life
new members can always try audible plus
for 30 days
on audible to use your audible
membership you'll need to download the
audible app
the audible app is free and can be
installed on all smartphones and tablets
you can listen across devices like
amazon alexa enabled devices without
losing your spot
to get audible plus all you have to do
is
visit audible.com eisen or text eisen to
500-500
my daughter wants to listen to ramona on
audible maybe she'll do this for me
i'll probably have to do it myself visit
audible.com
eisen or text eisen eisen to 500
500.
from your world wrestling uh experience
your wwe
experience what would it be where you
were maybe
in the crowd and i mean you know with
the crowd around you something happening
you got a good one behind the scenes
even preparing meeting somebody
you got a good one man um yeah i guess
i guess it would be like uh anytime i
was with my wife
so we uh maurice and myself we actually
met
in wwe the first time i ever saw
my wife ever was on camera
and you could see when she walks in
my mouth is dropped because she is just
exudes just beauty and power
and charisma and she couldn't speak any
english
but you knew something was there like
you know she was trying out for a diva
search and i was a host
judge and it was incredible and then to
see
from there like our first interaction to
being in a wwe ring where
she was by my side and we made
the intercontinental championship which
at the time was
a title that the person whoever holding
it would always get beaten
it was kind of beaten and it wasn't it
wasn't the prestigious title that i
remember
as a kid it was just a side title that
was just there to hold and
be grandiose and so our goal was to set
out to make it the most prestigious
relevant title in all of wwe
and those two years with her by my side
you know were the best in my opinion
because
i i mean anytime you're in a speedo
you're half naked in front of your wife
you know you're gonna show off a little
bit you know
so i mean that's all i was doing is just
like
i was showing off for my wife to to
hopefully thinks that i was sexy and
just a badass and a you know beating up
people
like let's go and uh and so
it all came into uh where we actually
were at tag team partners at
wrestlemania
and uh and i remember going out in the
ramp
and looking at her and she was right in
front of me and i was like man
how did i get her like how did how did i
get someone like her so smart beautiful
confident i remember
i remember the first time we uh i asked
her out like
i wasn't even on a date it was like
after the show everyone goes out after
the show to get something to eat
to talk about the show so i invited her
and we ended up staying in a parking lot
and i remember driving
and we were driving back to the hotel
and i go pull over pull over pull over
and we pull over and we go into this
this sex toy shop because i wanted her
to know that i didn't want to be in the
friend zone with her you know
that's a way by the way that's that's
that's that's an indication
that's an indication that's what's one
way to work right yeah i'm not subtle
i'm not subtle so i think i freaked her
out a little bit
uh when we went in there because like as
soon as we walk in there's like
mannequins with like
ball gags and like things all around
and i'm like maybe this wasn't the
smartest
idea but i will say this yes
we walked out out of there like three
minutes later because she was not having
it she goes this is too weird
and we ended up talking for like three
hours before our flight and then we just
drove
our flights went our separate ways and
i remember going to barnes noble that
day
and getting a french-speaking book to
learn how to speak french because we
didn't have apps back then
right and uh and i remember asking
telling myself like if
i could only get a girl like this that'd
be really happy
and then cut to me and her as husband
and wife
walking down the the ramp at
wrestlemania
tagging together like that's surreal
that doesn't happen
no that's like incredible now you got
your own show with her too
i know ms and mrs uh mondays on the usa
network 11 10 central right after raw
it's
it's honestly it's our baby we love this
show it brings our family together
like the only time my dad wants to hang
out with me is if we're filming
uh i'll even ask him hey you want to
come over for like a holiday he's like
nah
that's all right are you filming and if
i say yes he'll be like yeah i'm over
but if i say no he's like nah i'll wait
till you're filming
but uh but yeah like it's it brings our
family closer together and we're finding
new things about like for instance
this season my mom and marjo are want to
get out there again
like they want to find a companion like
my mom and
hasn't been out on a date in probably 20
years so
we kind of help him out but honestly
maurice and i have been out of the game
for a very long time as well we don't
understand the swipe right swipe
left we don't have to sliding into dms
these whole things like my mom's
teaching me stuff that i'm like i don't
want to hear about this
[Music]
so yeah that's what's going on on the
miz and misses out front
oh man it is so cool what you got going
on dude i think we can all agree that
running to the store has been pretty
stressful lately
and there's nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list and
needing to make multiple trips
shopping for home essentials should be
easy and convenient that's where my
friends at grove collaborative comes in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online and get all the natural goods you
need for you and your family
plus shipping is fast and free on your
first order
join over two million households who
have trusted grove collaborative to make
their homes happier
and healthier again making the switch to
natural products has never been easier
for a limited time when my listeners go
to grove dot co slash
eisen you'll get to choose a free gift
with your first order of thirty dollars
or more but
you have to use our special code go to
grove.co
isen to get your exclusive offer that's
grove dot co
slash eisen
[Applause]
let's talk about your browns i mean
let's talk about it we're going to the
super bowl
we're going to the super bowl we were
going to the super bowl before the draft
and now we've picked up everything that
we slightly needed
like we needed a cornerback because
sometimes our cornerbacks get injured so
we got ourselves a cornerback we got
ourselves a safety linebackers
check check check like we got you know
what we have two
eight plus running backs and we were
like you know what let's add another
and let's add the fastest guy at the
combine
at wide receiver let's add him too let's
just throw them in the mix
and then by the way i saw like a uh a
tweet out from dez bryant yesterday
going uh
uh acl like what happened to odell's acl
because odell beckham
was literally training and he is fast
like real fast i don't know if you saw
that video oh yeah but
he looks fast and i'm like wait a second
so odell's still
fast we got jarvis we got hooper
we got hunt we got chubb baker's
uh all-star i mean what else do you
want and then we have all these draft
picks i'm ready to go yeah the defense
and you got the right coach and here's
the thing too the the crazy thing is
11 wins last year first playoff win
since bella checks the coach
you i mean that game against the
steelers you must have lost your mind
when you're up like the first quarter
you're gonna be kansas city chiefs
i honestly did i was like we're gonna
beat them we're gonna beat them
but now so we went to the playoffs and
that's that's that's one thing right
right go to the playoffs one thing to
win in the playoffs
now not only do you know how to get to
the playoffs you know how to win in the
playoffs
now it's figuring out how to get to the
super bowl that's the next step
and i think this year is that next step
well i mean here's the deal like you
said you wanted to run
at sofi for my charity at the very
beginning of this podcast how about
running in sofi
after the browns win the super bowl in
it how about that i'm in
i'll have my suit ready it'll be a
cleveland brown suit
and i'll be ready to go i will be
sprinting
you should if i if i pull a hammy so be
it whatever it doesn't matter what the
hell
certainly if the browns had one in the
building have you ever met baker have
you ever met baker making
i've never met baker no i've met jarvis
who
honestly when uh jarvis and miles
garrett and
both of them i just from a standpoint
like we were doing uh
i don't know if you remember but the
like bud light did the uh
browns coolers oh yeah if they wanted
him to cool the thing chains would drop
so the next year they were selling them
and i was the the
car the used car salesmen selling them
for their commercial yeah
and jarvis and miles came out and man
you could just sense the leadership and
the the pride that they have
for that city and uh i told uh
the browns were like hey what jersey do
you want this year i want jarvis landry
100
that's how much he impressed me uh he
became my new favorite player
just because of the demeanor uh
what we talked about like i didn't talk
to miles as much as i talked to jarvis
right it just
didn't end up that way but just speaking
with him i was like this guy is a locker
room leader
and you can tell this guy can really
change a locker room
and he believes in everything that he
says and again i know you're traveling
you're doing a lot with your kids i
don't know if you saw miles garrett
announce the pick at the draft he was in
this
in this velvet like
i mean just like he is he was like i
think he lean i think i think he was
flexing as he leaned over the podium he
was like literally underneath
the hole it's just there it just muscles
upon muscles
and not only that like i think he's
going to be defensive player of the year
could be
and now that now with you know having
someone else on the other end
you know i think they can't double team
him anymore and
he's just going to be absolutely insane
so they got clowny too
i mean dude that's what i'm saying dude
they
they are literally stacked they can't
double team garrett anymore
and it's gonna be i feel sorry for any
quarterback in the afc north
all right um again i appreciate you
doing this uh especially
on a day where you're shooting raw and
um you know i
before you leave what would you say to
somebody who is
listening to this learning your story
maybe for the first time obviously
fans of yours are familiar with how you
did get on tv
but not maybe the stick-to-itiveness and
how you were
of single-mindedness to get where you
are
and then from where you are you meet
your wife and your children are
essentially
uh uh here on the planet with your wife
due to your determination for all these
years
so what do you say to somebody who's
like wondering if
they need some sort of push to get
started on something what do you say
i've given this advice to a couple of my
friends who are like yeah
you know i want to do this and i go okay
what are the tools
that will get you so first off figure
out what you want in life
what do you want that's what you need to
answer if you can't answer that question
then what are we doing here like what do
you want what will make you happy what
will make you smile
each and every day then find the tools
that can allow you to do whatever you
want
successfully so what did i do i wanted
to be a wwe superstar
what are the tools that will get me
there wrestling school
that will teach me the techniques acting
classes because let's face it
you need a character you need to figure
all those things out improv
classes we're live you get one take and
you got a live audience in front of you
you never know what's going to happen i
need to have the correct
athletic build i need to make sure that
i'm working out i need a nutritionist to
make sure that i'm eating the correct
foods
to to make sure that i'm able to perform
at a top level each and every day
those are the tools that i find so find
the tools that you need
to do whatever you want successfully
you're good man ms
thanks for doing the pod hey thank you
so much i really appreciate you always
uh
you know having me come on and i always
love what you do with st jude
thanks and then you were so supportive i
mean you you were
you actually told an entire arena filled
with people this was two years ago
before pandemic and everything you you
got out there and
you told everybody to start donating to
run richmond i forget where you exactly
were but
you were in full character and you got
up there and you set it to a full arena
of people and it put my
it put you know your platform is so huge
um and i appreciate you lending it to
this show too
appreciate it always man always for a
good cause i appreciate it that's the
myth
thank you very much i'm gonna go do
monday night raw
and uh put on a hell of a show like i
always do you do that's
the miz i'm just getting started that's
the miz everybody
and he's just such a big personality
big-hearted guy you know that he plays a
heel
or as he said people who they love to
hate him
throughout his career um and he's just
the exact opposite
and always giving like i said that he uh
what he did a few years ago
telling his fans in an arena i think it
was in minnesota or something like that
packed
there he is in his full getup and outfit
and just telling everybody hey
go to nfl.com run rich run for saint
jude like he had the whole
uh spiel all the details for my
for my run and how you can donate to
saint jude and by the way it still works
nfl.com
run rich run where i run my 40 yard dash
um
in support of saint jude children's
research hospital and
we just aired the finale on the nfl
draft usually it's done at the nfl
combine in february but because that got
canceled due to covert this year
we ran at sofi stadium at hollywood park
the home of the rams and the
chargers in this year's super bowl as
the miz was referring to
to start this podcast so um
he's so giving and uh if you want to
give please do
we're raising money as much as we can
for saint jude children's research
hospital still go there and
his story about how he just stuck to it
uh to get on
uh mtv uh to get on the real world and
what he did from that
um so many people just assume that you
know fame will just come find you after
that as opposed to still having a plan
of what to do with your fame
it's an important thing for everyone to
recognize that even if what you do
put your mind to and just assuming that
you are successful
at it that more success will follow and
that's not true it just means you got to
put in more hard work to be
successful and get it bigger and better
and not sleep
not just rest on some sort of a laurel
that you got to the spot where you want
to go or you feel like you need to go
that there is still a master plan
there's still a greater plan and his
plan was to
join the wwe which he eventually got to
do
and he never wavered from it and it's a
good thing because there's two little
babies on the planet his daughters that
he that
exists due to his determination um
and you know i think that about my three
kids sometimes
that i met my wife in the newsroom at
espn
um in the mid to late 90s when i got
there in 1996 she
she was there just a few months later um
as
a producer and then she started her
on-air career after that
but you know the number of times that i
thought to myself
do i really have it in me to get a tv
job like how do i go about it what
should i do
um i know i'm going to be up against a
million people getting doors slammed in
my face by news directors they don't
want to give me a job they don't think
that i'm
good enough or the opportunity isn't
there and how do i follow up on that and
i've always constantly worked at it
even after 25 years of being in in
the business this podcast is an example
of trying to diversify
and talk about subject matters that i
don't uh
usually talk about certainly on nfl
network or
even my daily show every day which you
can get in podcast form
so yes i'll even self-promote while on
another podcast
but um to continue to have a plan and
continue to work at it the number of
times where i could have just said you
know what
i don't know if i have it in me to
continue on to get my first tv job and
succeed at it and once there how do i
continue to work at it to get where i
wanted to go which was espn and
sent a tape to a headhunter under the
category of
why not all it is is just first class
postage
somebody saw it and followed up on it
and
it was like i got struck by lightning it
was a lottery ticket
but it was all about the residue of
design
of me continuing and having a
singularity of focus
and not resting on any laurels and to
hear the miz tell
that story about how many hoops he had
to run through just to get his first
opportunity
and how many hoops he jumped through and
how many plans that he had
after that first opportunity to get the
one that he always wanted
and then being told he couldn't try out
for a show that he knew
would actually potentially lead to where
he wanted to go and
getting lucky so it changed hands and
thus he was able to actually try out for
it and
trying out even though he'd already had
some success
i couldn't be more impressed and i'm so
glad and thrilled that
i was able to bring his story to you on
this podcast my last podcast
pat mcafee the ones before that uh gary
vaynerchuk
and uh harlan coleman you know
having soledad oh brian and matthew
mcconaughey was my first
guest it's uh it's been a nice uh
first couple of months of just getting
started bill burr the comedian go check
that out you can go to the rich eisen
show youtube page youtube.com
rich eisenshow2c just getting started
the entire podcast is placed right there
at youtube.com
rich eisenshow and also right here where
all podcasts are required
just download us hit that subscribe
button give us a five star rating
because
so many of uh the distributors of
podcasts
see it recognize it and allow us to
continue to do this
so we've got some great guests coming in
the pipeline can't wait to bring those
to you but that's it for this episode of
just getting started
[Applause]